when I got it thought I'd originally
only get six kegs back there but it
really is an eight head car I was
actually born ten blocks from here
studied brewing engineering at the
Technical University of Munich for four
and half years from the time I was 20
until now I came full circle
I can testify that the Model X can hold
eight four kegs of beer
be sure to buckle walls guys oh yeah I
never delivered beer before now if
someone calls up oh yeah I'll run it
over myself
[Music]
and it is the best delivery vehicle you
could ever imagine
I make excuses to go deliver beer
[Music]
it's a once-in-a-lifetime experience to
build a brewery like this because that
level of automation that we put in and
the the quality of the machinery our
brewery is fully automated so as my
Tesla I love technology as a whole
autopilot I'm addicted to it it makes
those frustrating drives and massive
traffic fun because it takes over for
you it is fun it is really fun
[Music]
I'm Dan Gordon I brew beer and I ha in a
Model X
[Music]